afternoon our royal commentator alastair
bruce there with reaction to that
breaking news that the duke of york will
be tried over allegations he sexually
assaulted virginia du frey when she was
under age a u.s judge has ruled that her
civil lawsuit can proceed
we expect that to start
um in september so later this year
outlining his reasons to deny a motion
to dismiss the civil case against the
duke of york the judge involved judge
louis kaplan said ms dufrey's complaint
is neither unintelligible nor vague nor
ambiguous it alleges discreet incidents
of sexual abuse in particular
circumstances at three identifiable
locations it identifies to whom it
attributes that sexual abuse
the defendant nevertheless holds out
that he cannot reasonably prepare a
response because the plaintiff has not
described what purported sexual contact
occurred when and where the incident
occurred or the forcible compulsion she
was under due to express or implied
threat to the degree of specificity he
would like while he understandably seeks
more detail about the precise details of
the plaintiff's claims he will be unable
to obtain that detail during pre-trial
discovery moreover the defendant's
assertion that he cannot reasonably
prepare a response to the plaintiff's
allegations plainly contradicts the
content of his moving papers in which he
denies ms dufrey's allegations in no
uncertain terms well that is what the
judge has had to say in explaining why
he has
denied a motion to dismiss this civil
case let's bring in mark stevens
international lawyer at howard
kennedy mark stevens good to see you
this afternoon your reaction to this
breaking news this afternoon
i think this was not particularly
surprising sarah jane as a consequence
of the way in which this case was argued
i think
we all thought that prince andrew was
not going to be successful today um i
think this judge will set the sort of
aggressive timetable that he's indicated
previously but i think he knows he's
also
probably going to be the subject of an
appeal by prince andrew's legal team
and so
he'll likely list it for towards the end
of november the beginning of december
which will give a window of opportunity
for prince andrew's team not only to
prepare for the trial but also to
conduct any appeal that they think is uh
going to be viable
so mark from this point on we can
expect an appeal from prince andrew's
team and perhaps a settlement as well as
so often happens before uh these civil
cases are
taken further
yes i think that's right i think the
situation here is that there is a good
legal point that um the position is that
the uh prince andrews legal team have
been stonewalling it's clearly that
which has irritated this judge who
thinks that they should get to the
merits quickly um and
but one of the points that they've come
across this one about the settlement
does have some merit and it's not a slam
dunk for either side and you can see the
legal merits shown of the morality of
this particular case some would say
immorality of this case that um
he can appeal and he's got good grounds
to do so but i suspect that this is a
case which is going to go to trial and
the stonewalling tactics of prince
andrew's lawyers have been to attempt to
delay he's not in a great position now
uh he's not can he get in a better
position no he can't can he make it
worse yes he can make an awful lot worse
by going to america and having to give
evidence and i think
the only option if he fails on his
appeal is to settle everybody will take
that as an admission of guilt but it's
less damaging for him than to go through
the trial the public spectacle of the
details of what happened and of course
many people will think much the worse of
him if he puts virginia joffrey through
the mill of having to go to court as we
saw with the uh jalae maxwell women had
to go through and relive their
experiences in public fairly traumatic i
think mr freya
suing the queen's son for allegedly
sexually assaulting her when she was a
teenager the duke has vehemently denied
these allegations and his legal team has
argued from the lawsuit's first hearing
that the case is baseless however we now
have the prospect of this civil case
towards the end of the year we
understand that virginia du frey is
seeking unspecified damages but there is
speculation that the sun could be in the
millions of dollars mark
yes and i think that the answer to that
is absolutely uh she had the opportunity
of suing in london um she wouldn't have
got anything like the damages in america
in america i think you can expect to see
um many millions of dollars in damages
and so i think that uh
if he's going to be shelling out for
lawyers and showing out for damages he
may be better off cutting his losses and
just showing out to virginia joffrey
settling this draw a line he's not going
to be rehabilitated but he protects the
rest of the royal family from what would
otherwise be an appallingly damaging
experience of him fighting these kinds
of allegations in court in public um
mark stevens if the hearing does go
ahead it's not clear whether prince
andrew will give evidence in person via
a video link or decline to participate
yeah there's a there's a quirk of uh law
between england and america so if he
if virginia joffrey obtains what's
called a default judgment that is prince
andrew doesn't turn up to defend himself
she will be able to get a vindication
from the court in new york but the
damage award that the jury gives her
will not be enforceable in this country
prince prince andrew and indeed any
defendant in this country who gets a
default judgment against them in america
it's not enforceable here so they can
only go against assets in america and of
course prince andrew won't have any
there so
that would be a sort of pyrrhic victory
but i think the moral uh a program that
would come on prince andrew uh taking
advantage of a technicality of that kind
would just be too great uh to withstand
so this case has always been about
damage limitation the stakes just went
up and there's going to have to be some
serious damage limitation now i can't
see a situation where the royal family
or indeed their legal advisers are going
to let prince andrew first of all go on
oath on videotape for depositions so
they take video of the witness giving
evidence under oath under
cross-examination and then they replay
that at the trial and cross-examine them
on that in this country we reduce it all
into writing so you have witness
statements again under oath and you
cross examination on them all right mark
stevens good to have you it's going to
be too terrible mark steve it's good to
have your expertise guiding us through
what's happening this afternoon mark
stevens international lawyer howard
kennedy thank you it is three o'clock
our breaking news this afternoon the
duke of york will face a civil sex case
trial after a u.s judge dismissed a
motion by prince andrew's legal team to
have the lawsuit thrown out the case has
been brought by virginia du frey who
claims that she was abused by prince
andrew when she was 17. prince andrew's
lawyer claimed a previous settlement
agreed between miss dufrey and the sex
offender jeffrey epstein meant she could
not claim further damages the duke of
york denies all the allegations made
against him our role correspondent
rihanna mills has this report
a business event in davos in january
2015 was the first time prince andrew
publicly responded to the allegations
i've just wished to reiterate
and to reaffirm the statements which
have already been made on my behalf
by buckingham palace
my focus
is on my work
in the seven years since then the claims
from virginia dufrey and this photograph
have continued to haunt him
his attempt to shut it down with this
interview two years ago backfired i i
have no recollection of ever meeting her
and instead forced him to step down from
royal duties
his state of self-imposed exile mainly
at raw lodge on the windsor estate led
some charities to cut ties with him but
he still has links with a large number
of organizations even though he can't
represent them in public
and more controversially he has retained
his ceremonial military titles
including honorary colonel of the
grenadier guards
the decision by the judge to allow this
civil case to continue severely hampers
any hope of rebuilding his reputation
anytime soon he's still um
the uh
colonel cohen chief of a number of um
regiments uh in the british
armed forces um which are in the
personal gift of his mother and and he
hasn't been stripped of those
but it's very difficult to see him
coming out in public and
i mean who would speak to him
reportedly the queen's favorite son
there was a time where his military
service in the falklands was celebrated
in the papers but in recent years
headlines been dominated by his
relationship with pedophile jeffrey
epstein and gillane maxwell difficult
not just for him but the rest of the
royal family there's absolutely no doubt
that whatever happens whatever good work
whatever attempts charles and william
have to to try and find a sort of modern
relevant face of monarchy that
re-engages with people after the death
of the queen that prince andrew and the
issues associated that i'm not taking
responsibility really and being seen to
apparently kind of duck and dive process
is something that is going to really um
hang heavy i think over the royal family
over the next few years
prince andrew's absence has been
particularly notable as his siblings
have stepped up to be there for the
queen
privately they may be supportive of him
but publicly they have tried to distance
themselves from the scandal they will no
doubt want to keep that silence as this
deeply damaging saga continues
rhiannon mills sky news
well let's get more from our
correspondent joe pike who was covering
the story from new york and joins us now
um joe the judge making this ruling
within the last half an hour what was
his explanation for finding in favor of
virginia du frey
well the key argument sarah jane that
prince andrew's lawyers made at the
start of last week in that court hearing
was
that there was this 2009 settlement
between virginia dufrey and the
pedophile jeffrey epstein she received
500 000
dollars within that settlement and in
the text of the settlement she agreed to
not pursue other people in civil
proceedings connected to mr epstein so
the debate within court that day
was all about whether prince andrew is
covered and the judge and his very long
ruling 40 or so pages he said that 2009
agreement cannot be said to demonstrate
clearly and unambiguously that the
parties intended the instrument directly
primarily or substantially to benefit
prince andrew this is not a huge
surprise because in that hearing the
judge lewis cat plan was interrogating
the lawyers for either side and he
seemed dismissive and skeptical of the
legal arguments being made by prince
andrews lawyer
it wouldn't have been um
good uh it would have been a good look i
don't think if prince andrew had won
this motion to dismiss because
ultimately
he would be
relying on that very controversial
settlement he would effectively be
saying to virginiji frey you can't sue
me because you settled with my
paedophile friend now his allies would
argue on the other hand that this is
about money she has already received
money and it's not fair that she should
pursue others too her allegation is that
prince andrew sexually assaulted her
three times when she was 17 years old in
three locations firstly in getty
maxwell's home in london this is where
this picture is taken reportedly the
the photographer at this point was
jeffrey epstein himself the late uh
pedophile
the second location was new york where
jeffrey epstein had a large home on the
upper east side and the third place that
virginia dufrese alleges she would was
abused by prince andrew
is on one of jeffrey epstein's uh
islands in the u.s
virgin islands now prince andrew has
consistently and strenuously uh denied
all of those allegations but what we're
moving to now is the sort of second
stage of this process of discovery where
we could find out more
about the evidence that either side is
holding it's almost like they've held
their cards quite close to their chest
so far now they need to explain what
they have that could see prince andrew
and virginia dufrey being deposed them
being questioned out of court but under
sworn oath and that evidence then being
submitted to the court but of course it
is a massive massive moment of danger
and jeopardy for the duke of york
effectively his reputation whether it's
fair or not has already been damaged
we're now talking about how far
these allegations affect uh the
reputation of the royal family and i
think that will be in the minds of the
courtiers and key people involved in
deciding whether or not to settle that
is a big decision for prince andrew now
does he settle with virginia du frey do
they come
to a legal agreement one that would
involve likely millions of dollars
and what does virginia dufrey want to do
does she want to settle does she want
the money or ultimately does she want to
pursue justice and the truth she could
make this very awkward for the duke of
york and for the royal family
by continuing dragging this out
trying to force a trial even though
trials in civil cases
are incredibly rare
certainly whatever you think about the
duke of york whatever you think about
these allegations that he's consistently
denied we do know that two of his close
friends were a pedophile in geoffrey
epstein and a child sex trafficker in
gilay maxwell that has damaged his
reputation possibly irreparably it's now
sarah jane up to him and others within
the palaces to decide how much all of
this affects the reputation of the royal
family hey joe pike thank you the duke
of york of course denies all allegations
and buckingham palace today declining to
comment to this breaking news this
latest development saying we would not
comment on what is an ongoing legal
matter
let's speak now to spencer kuvin a
lawyer representing many of jeffrey
epstein's victims uh mr coover your
reaction to uh the breaking news this
afternoon
thank you for having me on this is a
pivotal moment in the case as uh
everyone has mentioned once a litigant
gets past the point of a motion to
dismiss
that opens the door to discovery in any
civil litigation discovery includes
written discovery requests for documents
but it also includes most importantly
and significantly for the duke a
deposition
and there is no doubt that the attorneys
for virginia guffrey are going to seek
to take the deposition of the duke of
york in addition to that they could seek
depositions of any other individuals who
may have been present that could include
anyone within the royal family that may
have been present during uh any of the
conversations or anything that may have
been said
after the incident or that could verify
any of his background and alibi that he
has stated very publicly in the
interview that he gave
and mr keith perhaps you could explain
how a deposition works because it's not
something we're familiar here with in
the uk it's very much something that
happens in the us a legal system and
what is a deposition can prince andrew
refuse to participate
as a defendant in a case a
person cannot refuse
to come forward for a sworn deposition a
deposition is sworn testimony it's taken
under oath under penalty of perjury of
the u.s law
and
as many people may know or may not know
a few of the charges that were lodged
against gohan maxwell which she is now
being charged criminally with and could
be prosecuted on
were that she lied under oath in a civil
deposition that was taken in another
matter
so a civil deposition taken under oath
under penalty of perjury of u.s law is
very serious
and as a result anything that is said
under oath must be the truth the whole
truth and nothing but the truth
and if someone lies under oath that is a
criminal prosecution in and of itself
that could take place
these types of sworn testimony are taken
every day
i do hundreds of them a year in civil
cases and i took numerous depositions of
these
witnesses in the jeffrey epstein matters
when i represented those young girls
here in the state of florida
uh those depositions a person appears
there could be a video camera there is
always a court reporter taking down
everything that is said
and the duke would be entitled to have
his own attorney present for that sworn
testimony and then the attorneys for
virginia great could ask any question
they wanted
now as a civil civil litigator in the uh
u.s
you have a constitutional right against
self-incrimination
so uh because this is a u.s lawsuit
the duke may
refuse to answer questions under oath
on the grounds that it may incriminate
him which is exactly what by the way
jeffrey epstein did when i took his
deposition in the litigation here in the
states who else can be deposed because
there is a lot being made because of the
high profile of this case about for
instance members of the royal family
being deposed or high-profile friends of
prince andrew being deposed do they have
to give a deposition or can they refuse
to take part because for prince andrew
this could get extremely messy and as as
we say from his point of view it is all
about protecting his innocence and his
reputation
yes so in a civil litigation any witness
with potential information can be
deposed now the attorneys for virginia
gefrey will have to make a showing of
why they want to take the deposition of
someone uh who may be a member of the
royal family and they must make that
showing to the court and then request
the court's permission if it is someone
of uh of pivotal importance
now generally uh any potential witness
is subject to the subpoena power of the
attorneys that are involved in the case
as an attorney and a member of the bar
for the u.s courts and the florida
courts here in the united states
i can issue a subpoena for someone to
appear for deposition and if they refuse
to comply with that subpoena they could
actually be held in contempt and put
under arrest and taken to jail and then
made to appear for a deposition now
what's important about this law is that
it only applies if there is jurisdiction
over the person
so someone who is not physically located
here in the united states
may not be under the jurisdiction of the
court and therefore they may not be
compelled in certain circumstances
that's what i was going to lead on to
because many people will remember
when this first came to public light
there were a lot of questions about why
the duke of york would not travel to the
united states to answer uh questions
legal uh official you know all of that
how does that play this transatlantic
element play
into this civil case are there
difficulties with the defendant being in
the uk and the law in the united states
being all the way over there
yes that is going to be significant in
the case itself uh there are going to be
legal issues and i suspect they'll be
filed uh filing motions on this issue
for the court to rule on
whether or not certain individuals can
come within the jurisdiction of the
court in addition to that please don't
forget that at the time that this
incident occurred according to the
allegations and the complaint
the duke of york still potentially had
diplomatic immunity at that time now he
has since been stripped of that
by the queen but
the allegations of when this occurred
he may have had diplomatic immunity at
that time and i suspect that will be one
of the defenses to the case in addition
there is a concept called sovereign
immunity that needs to be argued to the
court at some point in the litigation
but that
will likely occur much later on in the
litigation in something called a summary
judgment proceeding and that would have
to occur after the depositions take
place now
as to
witnesses other than the duke of york
those individuals have to be under the
jurisdiction of the court they must be
here in the united states to be deposed
otherwise they would have to come here
from out of country to volunteer for a
deposition okay spencer really good to
explore this with you and look at some
of the potential bumps in the road as we
look towards this civil case that that
could be taking place towards the end of
the year we understand september or
around then and just a final question if
i may because as spencer coover knew
represented a number of the victims of
jeffrey epstein and virginia dufrey
who's bought this civil case is perhaps
the most high-profile
victim to go public and the duke of york
of course denies all allegations against
him but for virginia du frey and vic
alleged victims of sexual assault what
does this say about the reach of the law
and that no one is above it
yes and thank you for that
you know one of the significant things
to remember and i represent victims of
sexual assault um across the united
states and have been for many years
is that sexual assault is something that
occurs to
anyone and everyone it happens to young
boys it happens to young women
it happens to older women older men
this
occurs across the world not just here in
the united states and certainly not even
in just the uk
so for victims to see someone with
wealth and power
especially with the prosecution and
conviction of glenn maxwell and now the
continuing and ongoing litigation
against the duke of york
it empowers those victims to be able to
come forward and speak their truth and
that is an incredibly important thing
and justice may be slow
but
justice does come eventually so what i
would say to anyone
who is
um
you know
doing these types of acts justice will
come your way eventually
uh spencer kuvin a lawyer representing
many of jeffrey epstein's victims really
um appreciate the
level of your expertise talking us
through these potent potential
proceedings later in the year
and of course talking about the victims
and sexual abuse thank you so much for
talking to us here on sky news this
afternoon
uh we're just a reminder of the breaking
news this afternoon uh the duke of york
is going to be tried over allegations he
sexually assaulted virginia dufrey when
she was under age a u.s judge has ruled
that her civil lawsuit can proceed the
duke of york denies all allegations
against him it's thought that the civil
lawsuit the case will get underway
towards the end of the year the judge
that made this ruling was judge louis
kaplan he published a lengthy ruling
this afternoon as he delivered his
decision here's some of what he had to
say
the 2009 agreement cannot be said to
demonstrate clearly and unambiguously
the parties intended the instrument
directly primarily or substantially to
benefit prince andrew this is in
relation to the agreement made between
virginia du frey and the convicted
pedophile jeffrey epstein he goes on to
say the existence of the requisite
intent to benefit him or others
comparable to him is an issue of fact
that could not properly be decided on
this motion even if the defendant fell
within the releasing language which
itself is ambiguous
well we can get more reaction now from
john arledge senior writer for the
sunday times who interviewed prince
andrew in 2000 2017.
uh the decision not going the duke of
york's way today your reaction to this
decision from the us
viewers of your program and the rest of
sky news um have seen us talk about this
together um over the recent years and
we've always been
clear to say it'd be very very difficult
for the duke to prevail in this case and
so it's come to pass this really is the
nightmare scenario for the prince he has
from the outset tried to make this case
go away he's tried every single trick in
the book to make it go away and he's
failed and this was his last shot this
2009 agreement that was his last shot
the judge shot that down that means he
now has to engage with this court he now
has to give evidence he now has to
corroborate his story about pizza
express and in working and not being
able to sweat none of this none of this
will end well for him and i think right
now
they must be turning his he and his
lawyers must be turning their attention
to to see whether there's some way that
they can actually settle this case
before he has to engage with it because
all attempts to engage so far have ended
in disaster for him
is that your inkling of what will happen
because we've had some legal experts on
this afternoon saying
you know a settlement will be seen the
perception will be an admission of guilt
well it depends whether he can
uh
get as part of that settlement to say
that there's no emission of gold i mean
the difficulty for him is of course is
that an awful lot of people have already
made up their mind about this case
already
so
he's going to have to balance whether
what is going to be the least worst
option all options for him now are bad i
suspect all options for him mean that he
will have no further role in public life
whatsoever i think he's completely
finished totally finished the only
question now is how to limit the damage
is it going to be
better quote unquote to settle if he can
settle there's no reason that virginia
dufry will agree to settle but let's say
she did would that be
less bad than engaging with the the
court case now it's it's this is a this
is
i mean i can't imagine what he and his
legal team must be thinking now because
there is nothing nothing here that ends
well and as i said earlier i think this
really is is the end for the duke yeah
uh you think prince andrew is finished
after this regardless
of what the civil rights decision
finishing in his desire to to have any
kind of role in public life i i cannot
see how
he can appear
in public and meet and greet people
given what he's going to have
until proven guilty as well isn't it in
terms of the prince has denied all
allegations and you know people can
argue whether he went about it in the
right way or the wrong way in terms of
you know not facing uh up to
up to the law or to the allegations but
in terms of if the civil case finds in
his favor
you know from his point of view the
argument could be why shouldn't he um
return to public life he will have been
found he's innocent
if he wins the case then yes of course
but
if you look at what we know of this case
so far the two
pieces of evidence that he's presented
uh to as he would see it um get him off
the hook that the pizza express in
woking and the i don't sweat well he's
already admitted that he hasn't got any
independent corroboration of those two
pieces he's going to have to if he's
going to engage he's going to have to
give evidence now is he going to go to
america to give evidence well of course
he's not going to do that that would be
incredibly stupid so is he going to do
it on a video link well maybe he could
do it on a video link but as we know
from his interview with emily mate
he's completely hopeless at answering
questions any questions questions about
himself even he you know he ends up you
know making it 10 times worse than he
otherwise would have done if he said
nothing so every way he turns here i i i
think is is marked disaster
and and you can see that from the
history up until now so i think i
suspect there will be thought given now
to seeing if there's some form of no
liability settlement
but the problem there is you know will
the other side accept it will virginia
du3 accept it this is this is absolutely
cataclysmically awful for the duke it's
just it there's nothing nothing nothing
even remotely good in this judgment and
i i cannot cannot cannot see how he can
manage to come out of this with any
shred of public reputation unless by
some extraordinary turn of events he
engages with the action and he wins it
okay uh john
aldridge really good to talk to you this
afternoon and from the times thank you
very much he's interviewed prince andrew
um
those are his thoughts
on what has unfolded thank you for your
time i'm sure we will speak again uh
just to remind you of that breaking news
the duke of york is going to be tried
over allegations he sexually assaulted
virginia du frey when she was under age
a u.s judge ruled that her civil lawsuit
can proceed a little earlier i got the
views of our royal commentator alastair
bruce this was his reaction to today's
ruling
for victoria joyfre this must be the
most awful situation that she's faced
she's
gone through such awful things and the
allegations that she makes against the
duke of york must now be dealt with in
the civil case
and what i don't know much about the
process that now needs to take place i
know that it'll be a matter of enormous
concern to the queen and to other
members of the royal family and no doubt
the duke of york will have to seriously
consider the situation that he's in
yeah it's um virginia dufrese does get
to have her day in court she has long
fought for as as you said this will be
of concern uh for the royal family
what will be going on behind the scenes
because what a lot of people at home
will be thinking alistair is that this
shows that nobody is above the law
it's important that everyone is
reassured by that very thing
no one is above the law it doesn't
matter how grand or how smart or how
wealthy they may be
here is a woman with allegations that
are extremely serious the most serious
and the court has upheld her right to
have them heard and that is something
that
you know all of us should take
reassurance from
the difficulty is that obviously there
are two sides to every story
and that process must take its path
and it must be a matter of enormous
concern to any family that finds a
member of that family
presented with this kind of charge and
i'm sure for the queen who is a mother
and all mothers love their children
will find this particularly tough and
yet these cases now this case must now
be dealt with and it was go through the
proper process
and i'm sure that all people now are
thinking
most particularly about the poor woman
who has faced what must have been the
most awful things in her life and she
has these allegations and they must be
addressed this civil case is going to be
heard in new york alistair but it will
make headlines across the globe uh
prince andrew has taken a back seat when
it comes to royal duties we haven't seen
him publicly for some time now what will
happen to him in the interim
because a lot of people are saying you
know he still holds royal titles he
still has a number of duties will they
be taken away from him or will the civil
case not be pre-judged by the queen
this is a matter for the royal household
to advise the queen on now but we face a
different circumstance than we did
earlier on this has now been taken to a
different level by the judge's decision
and for the queen she will be looking
for advice but in the end her majesty
will make a decision and undoubtedly
what matters is that the institution
that she is responsible for maintaining
must be held above any scrutiny of too
great a degree that might bring it into
distribute
so you strike the right tone there when
you say what is of importance is this
case and these allegations are made by
virginia du frey
the alleged victim of sexual assault
here but just to put it into wider
context from your area of expertise as
our royal commentator this comes
at a big time for the royal family we
have embarked on the platinum jubilee
year
i think everyone understands that the
queen's role as head of state has been
beyond reproach for nearly 70 years and
that is one issue
everyone also knows that families are
complicated
and sometimes children find themselves
in difficult situations what matters
here though as i was saying before
is that virginia joyfray has made a very
clear allegation
and in the proper process of law that
must be attended to and if the queen
represents anything in our kingdom let
alone around the world and certainly
under the united states it's very
similar the queen represents the fact
that all people face the law equally
under the processes of that which has
been set up by statute and in accordance
with the judge's decision this process
must now go forward
let's join our correspondent ally
fortescue now she is outside buckingham
palace for us this afternoon to react to
the breaking news that the duke of york
will be facing a civil case uh regarding
allegations of sexual assault in the
united states um ali what happens next
well it is now very likely that this
civil case will go ahead martha kellner
our u.s correspondents saying that that
could happen as early as in september
these are allegations of course that
have dogged prince andrew for a long
time and there is no doubt that this is
a highly significant moment and highly
significant setback for the prince today
the civil trial the civil sex trial case
is now going to very likely be going
ahead that is an extraordinary situation
for a member of the royal family to be
in of course all of this is
because as we know to remind people
virginia dufrese suing prince andrew
claiming that he abused her when she was
17 years old she says
that she was trafficked around the world
by
jeffrey epstein the late
financier and forced to have sex with
prince andrew she says on a number of
occasions he of course has always
strenuously denied those allegations
you'll remember in that news night
interview he said he had never even met
virginia guffrey but now this will
likely be going to a trial his lawyers
on a number of occasions have tried to
throw this case out this latest attempt
was based on a deal a settlement that
was reached between miss guffrey and
jeffrey epstein
in which
it would stop
suing in connection with
people that were connected to mr epstein
but that the judge in new york today
decided would not be enough to stop this
to dismiss this case and it will now be
going ahead and of course that is a very
difficult thing not just for prince
andrew but for buckingham palace more
broadly
behind you buckingham palace have said
we will not comment on what is an
ongoing legal matter um well i was going
to talk to ali a bit more but she's
disappeared there she is um ali and we
won't expect to hear officially from
buckingham palace to comment on this
case as they just said in that statement
there but it really will shake the royal
family
undoubtedly and prince andrew's
reputation of course has been in in
tatters frankly for a long time he
stepped back from his royal duties in
2019 after
the the connection between him and
jeffrey epstein became so difficult to
manage led to so many difficult
uncomfortable headlines for the royal
family i think alistair bruce put it
well there when he said um that for the
queen all people will face the law
equally so she of course will be
balancing the difficulty of this being
her third child prince andrew facing
these allegations and these claims which
worth reminding people again he has
always denied and
her role as monarch so it is an
uncomfortable position for buckingham
palace to be in he of course had been
hoping i think to rebuild his reputation
but clearly that hasn't happened and a
very significant development today
was the latest from buckingham palace
thank you you're watching sky news
coming up on the break after the break
we'll have more on this breaking news
the duke of york to be tried over
allegations of sexual assault in a civil
case
in the united states uh the case brought
about by virginia du fray the duke of
york denying the allegations we'll have
more reaction for you after this break
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
uh welcome back you're watching sky news
the breaking news this afternoon the
duke of york is to face a civil trial in
the united states over claims of sexual
abuse after a judge dismissed prince
andrew's attempt to have this case
thrown out
prince andrew has always denied the
allegations made against him by a woman
who says she was a teenage victim the
woman in question virginia du frey well
we could speak now to mitchell eppner a
former federal prosecutor and attorney
with the new york law firm rottenberg
lippmann rich and good to speak to you
this afternoon thank you for joining us
here on sky news
thank you for having me um i'm happy to
share my knowledge with your viewers yes
we very much need it because this is a
civil case that is happening in the
united states so the law uh slightly
different to what may happen in the uk
so what we would like to know from you
is now that the judge has ruled that
this civil case can be brought in the
u.s what are the next steps
so the next step is something called
discovery that's the process by which
the parties share facts with each other
that will be composed of both document
discovery meaning that the prince would
be required to hand over documents
some of the documents that have been
requested are things like his travel
itineraries his medical records that
might corroborate or
demonstrate the falsity of his claim
that he can't sweat
there will also be depositions
deposition is a process by which a sworn
interview is taken in front of a court
reporter but not in front of a judge by
the opposing counsel uh prince andrew
would likely be uh sit for his
deposition in the uk
um but he would be under u.s oath
and he will be questioned by david boyes
who is
as far as most american lawyers are
concerned uh without peer as the
greatest deposition taker in modern
american jurisprudence um this is a very
very bad day for prince andrew
um
i have looked at reports that have been
coming out this afternoon obviously this
information
about this ruling uh you know just about
an hour old but we have known it's been
coming and there's been suggestions that
um any evidence given by prince andrew
as you put it the deposition part uh
could be done either in the u.s or by
video link in the uk but also
suggestions that he may not participate
does he have that option
the only way that he well yes he does
have that option he could opt not to
participate in one of two ways one is he
could assert his rights under the fifth
amendment to the united states
constitution which bars a person from
being forced to be a witness against
themselves in a criminal matter
but if that were to occur
oh no are you there
yes we can still hear you
sorry um if that were to occur um then
um then that fact could be presented to
the jury um as evidence against him in a
civil case and the judge might even uh
rule that
that fact alone creates civil liability
and the only question left would be
damages
the
only other way that he could avoid
testifying is to simply refuse to
participate in the case anymore at all
and take what's called a default again
there would then be a ruling on
liability against him and the only thing
left to be determined would be damages
so
there are only bad options in front of
him and he has to decide which of these
bad options is his best bad option okay
so they're the first two steps discovery
deposition
there is an option i understand as well
that it may not even get to those first
two steps because there may be a
settlement between prince andrew and the
woman making these allegations virginia
duprey who's bringing about the civil
well about 95 percent of american cases
settle before trial so settlement is
always a possibility the question is on
what terms and from what has been
released by
mr frey roberts attorneys they are not
interested in a settlement unless it
were to be accompanied by an
acknowledgement of liability and an
apology
i think that the money is secondary here
to both sides uh prince andrew clearly
has access to all the money in the world
even if he does not himself have that
money and miss jafre roberts has enough
money that she is not looking to this
lawsuit to pay her rent next month
okay so it may settle if it doesn't it
will go to discovery and depositions
once all that information has been
collected by both parties involved then
what
well then you have
an opportunity for final pre-trial
motions in some cases there would be an
opportunity to try to get the case
dismissed at that point that is not a
reasonable possibility here because
there will be evidence on both sides and
the judge is not in a position to take
the case away from the jury if there is
evidence on both sides so what would
happen would be uh final pre-trial
preparations
and then likely a trial i know that it's
currently scheduled for september my
expectation is that the trial would not
occur until closer to christmas or
early next early next year um just based
upon the way calendars tend to work in
the court um i've i've appeared in that
court many times and just one final
question mitchell epna what does that
day in court look like you mentioned a
jury there will there be a jury deciding
in this civil case if it does get to the
point of trial and also will prince
andrew and virginia dufrey be called on
to give evidence or some kind of
testimony on in that court given that
they've given death positions if you see
what i mean will we hear from them again
yes so those are two very good questions
first with regard to a jury uh yes
virginia dufrese roberts in her
complaint demanded a jury under the
american constitution she has an
absolute right to have this case tried
to a jury a civil jury in the united
states is composed of at least six
members
and they would have to be unanimous on
any verdict with regard to whether or
not the individuals will be there in
court
they are allowed to be
they are allowed to testify they are not
required to testify
but and this is a very important caveat
even if prince andrew has given
deposition testimony
that deposition testimony cannot be
introduced by prince andrew
he can only testify live
the only person who could introduce the
deposition testimony would be virginia
du frey a party cannot introduce their
own deposition testimony at trial they
are required to show up live to be um
subject to cross-examination live in
front of the jurors okay uh mitchell
etna a really good summary of what we
can expect um in this civil case board
against prince andrew thank you so much
for your expertise it's becoming so much
clearer what we're looking at and what
prince andrew will face uh later in the
year he of course denies all allegations
brought
by virginia du frey the woman who says
she was a teenage victim of sexual abuse
at the hands of the duke of york
right let's have a look at the other big
story today the prime minister earlier
in the house of commons apologizing
after finally breaking his silence and
admitting that he was at a bring your
own booze party in the downing street
garden during national lockdown boris
johnson has though argued it wasn't a
party but a work event we're doing a
heated pm queues earlier the labour
leader kirsten called on the prime
minister to resign we can listen now to
the prime minister's statement
mr speaker i want to apologize
i know that millions of people
across this country have made
extraordinary sacrifices
over the last 18 months
i know the anguish that they have been
through
unable
to mourn their relatives
unable to live their lives as they want
or to do the things
they love
and i know the rage
they feel
with me
[Music]
and with the government i lead
when they think that in downing street
itself
the rules are not being properly
followed by the people who make the
rules
and though i cannot anticipate the
conclusions of the current inquiry
i have learned enough to know that there
were things
we simply
did not get right
and i must take responsibility
[Applause]
number 10 is a big department
with the gardeners as an extension of
the office
which has been in constant use because
of the role of fresh air in stopping the
virus
and when i went into that garden just
after six on the 20th of may
2020
[Music]
to thank groups of staff before going
back into my office 25 minutes later to
continue working
i believed implicitly that this was
a work event
but mr speaker
with hindsight
i should have sent
everyone back inside
i should have found some other way
to thank them
and i should have recognized that
even if it could be said technically to
fall
within the guidance
there would be millions and millions of
people
who simply would not see it that way
people who suffered terribly
people who were forbidden from meeting
loved ones at all
inside or outside
and
to them and to this house i offer my
heartfelt apologies
and all i ask is that sue gravy allowed
to complete her inquiry into that day
and several others so that the full
facts can be established and i will of
course come back to this house and make
a statement
let's join our deputy political editor
sam coats now who's live in central
lobby in the palace of westminster and
sam you've been speaking to mps as
they've walked through central lobby uh
after that statement from the prime
minister this afternoon what have they
been saying to you
there's a big discussion underway inside
the conservative party about the prime
minister's future there's no doubt about
that boris johnson offering what many
people think of as something of a
qualified
apology apologizing for those 25 minutes
on may the 20th 2020 in which he was
outside what other people see as a party
his line of defenses i didn't realize it
was a party i thought it was a work
event it's enough for some mps in public
some tories saying we're glad that he
has now uh apologized for uh what
happened but for many tory mps they're
asking the question whether or not
that'll wash whether it'll wash in a
week or two's time when we get a report
from sue gray a senior official into
exactly what did happen that day
and what happened in that roughly dozen
or so events where number 10 another
bits of whitehall looked like they were
celebrating
you've got meetings of the 1922
executive of tory mps
later today um you've got several mps
coming up to me in private and saying i
think boris johnson is done for some
loyalists we heard from conor burns a
northern ireland minister a long time
friend of the prime minister earlier
saying no i think he's done the right
thing
let's give this some time to blow over
see what the report says but i trust the
prime minister but there are big
conversations difficult conversations
about the pm's future going on at the
moment
all around me in the palace of
westminster it's not quite clear where
this is going to end up
france's premiership is in the hands of
tory mps um or it could be in the hands
of sue gray depending on the findings of
her report that we are expecting perhaps
at the end of next week and you
mentioned earlier on sam that that might
be delayed if there was an inquiry by
the metropolitan police into that party
on may the 20th and we have had a
statement from the met today
that's right now the met police haven't
exactly jumped at the opportunity to
investigate much of the
goings-on that you've been reading about
and watching on sky news the
metropolitan police were releasing a
statement really restating
that position they say that they don't
like investigating
things breaches of coronavirus
restrictions that were long ago so at
the moment they indicate that they are
unlikely to tell them to take any
further action but the statement from
the metropolitan police say that could
change if the cabinet office uh say
something different and bring something
to their attention what does that mean
well that's a reference to the see grey
report in other words if this incredibly
powerful civil servant now uh sue grey
who has to determine the future of the
prime minister of his government
says in
in terms or explicitly in her report
there was law breaking uh then the
metropolitan police could still
investigate boris johnson's statement of
course very carefully worded today um to
apologize uh if there was the perception
uh that he'd broken the rules but no
admission that he'd broken the law
saying he thought it was a work party uh
that's uh a statement drawn up for legal
reasons uh and also a qualified apology
the question is is it gonna wash with
everybody is it gonna wash with the
public or not so we're just going to
have to give it some time and find out
okay sam thank you sam coates uh with
the latest from westminster uh you're
watching the sarah james show here on
sky news uh coming up after the break
proceedings against prince andrew have
been allowed to continue a u.s judge has
rejected the duke's attempts to have a
civil sex case against him thrown out
[Music]
back during the soviet era a
natural gas drilling operation collapsed
into a sinkhole
and at some point we're not exactly sure
when some say 1971 some say
uh the late or the 1980s at some point
it was lit on fire and all of this
methane gas that's coming up out of the
ground
lit and has remained lit ever since for
about 50 years or so and the
turkmenistan government every few years
or so they say that they want to
extinguish it and tap into that natural
gas resource the president has recently
stated that's what they want to do now
and we'll see what happens but right now
it's actually become the number one
tourist attraction in all of
turkmenistan believe it or not
it was
two years of planning and preparation
and i was able to bring my team into
turkmenistan with tremendous difficulty
and rigged fire resistant ropes and
specialized heat protective equipment
and dropped down to the very bottom with
only 17 minutes worth of air the purpose
was to gather soil samples from the
bottom looking for any type of bacteria
living at the bottom that could give us
clues as to where we might want to send
our space probes in the future to look
for life on other planets because it is
such an exotic place
how did you not die
well a lot of preparation
a lot of specialized custom equipment my
climbing hardness had to be made out of
kevlar because a regular climbing
harness would have melted from the
extreme heat i measured a ground
temperature of 400 degrees celsius
uh and of course limiting your time down
there is is the key i only had a certain
amount of air because we didn't trust
the quality of the air down there and of
course you don't want to breathe in 400
degree air
we know it's been burning for so long so
it's understandable that there's a
tremendous financial reason to tap into
this natural gas that's down there but
at the same time doing that would be
extremely difficult and very expensive
to do and would basically eliminate all
of the tourism money that comes in for
people who want to go and view this
particular place and i've been there
several times over the years and the
tourism infrastructure around the crater
has really developed uh when i was there
in 2013 there was nothing but now
there's a fence around it there are
flush toilets there are uh campsites and
picnic tables and it's actually uh the
number one tourist
attraction people come from all over the
world to go see the gates of hell
hello welcome back busy afternoon here
on sky news um our top story prince
andrew is going to be tried over
allegations he sexually assaulted
virginia dufrey when she was under age
this is after a u.s judge ruled that her
civil lawsuit can go ahead uh well
joining me now nigel kaufel author of
prince andrew epstein and the palace and
nigel good to see you this afternoon
thank you for joining us here on sky
news
uh well this is another chapter uh for
your book should you
wish to have another
run of it come out soon um it wasn't
entirely unexpected but what do you make
of the decision by the u.s judge today
well i think it's what we expected um um
judge kaplan was pretty scathing
about the arguments that uh prince
andrew's
defense lawyers put up um so
it's taken a bit of time to write it up
but
i think we've got what we expected
yeah it's definitely worth reminding
people of the defense that prince
andrews legal team took to the u.s
last week in terms of trying to get
virginia due phrase case thrown out
because it all hinged on an agreement
she signed back in 2009 with the
pedophile jeffrey epstein
yes indeed um it was rather an
extraordinary um
idea that his defense uh
team came up with because i don't think
it could do
prince andrew's reputation any good to
if it
seemed to be dodging the bullet but by
some sleazy agreement signed by a
convicted pedophile um
and
if it's the the uh the settlement
agreed uh the the non-prosecution uh uh
clause
that virginia gouffrey couldn't uh sue
anyone else involved this
the the
the case there was about sex trafficking
so um and no one's accused prince andrew
of sex trafficking so
he would
have
said he wasn't um
a defendant in in that sort of case um
which i say no one was accused of nigel
in your opinion how messy does this get
because of course our correspondent joe
pike who's been following this story put
it succinctly um earlier on saying that
the reputation of prince andrew is in
tatters friends with a convicted
pedophile a convicted
sex trafficker
and now this
can he come back from this obviously
we're not pre-judging um this civil
trial innocent and two proven guilty he
refutes all of the allegations but can
his reputation survive either way
in indeed i don't think it can because
we look at that picture that you just
showed
in a in a different light now
after galen maxwell's conviction because
there we have a a woman who's been
convicted for sex trafficking and we
have a a 17 year old girl
um virginia robertson she then was
saying that she was she was trafficked
and there's prince andrew saying that he
wasn't there
it seems extraordinary he's he's tried
to cast aspersions on on the picture but
so there's been no evidence that it is
in any way faked
and just referring back to the title of
your book prince andrew epstein and the
palace the palace have said this
afternoon they don't comment on ongoing
legal matters but this will have shaken
the royal family today
one in in indeed because um
there's money involved um
if there is a settlement which i think
that virginia goofy is not really going
for she's i think she wants her day in
court she was denied that in the maxwell
case she may be denied uh that in in the
the outstanding perjury charges against
uh
killing maxwell which the prosecution
may drop um
and i think she wants she wants to stand
up in front of the world and tell the
world what happened to her um
or at least her version of what happened
to her so that's going to be a very
expensive process if if but if prince
andrew makes a settlement i'm sure
surely the taxpayers of this country
will ask exactly where this money is
coming from um already that there's been
disquiet about uh the fact that the
queen
is is
said to be paying for his defense um
which
apparently prince charles and prince
william uh
are rather against but it also it's
always also been reported
that the money is coming from from
time we've run out of time but i'm sure
we will speak to you in the coming weeks
as this unfolds thank you so much for
your time thank you
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so
[Music]
it's four o'clock you're watching the
sarah j may show coming up breaking news
the duke of york will face a civil sex
case trial in the united states after a
judge dismissed the motion to have the
lawsuit thrown out
well the case threatens to overshow the
overshadow the queen's platinum jubilee
which takes place this year
also this afternoon the prime minister
apologizes after confirming he was at a
party in his downing street garden
during lockdown but says he thought it
was a work event i want to apologize